they're here i am again it's the third  of january it's our last day of  bratislava behind me is the city museum  which we're going to go visit learn a  bit more about the history of Bratislava  we're taking the train off to Prague  last night we had a fabulous evening we  met with a total of five linkers here in  Bratislava we had a lovely dinner then  we went to a wine bar where we drank  some wine and we talked about and we  talk in English and in check and we  talked about language learning history  and and there's so much history  surrounding us so I'm looking forward to  going to the museum as much as I have  enjoyed the whole trip language travel  history food wine what more can you ask  for bye for now